okay so as we saw right this was a good
example uh of uh some of the work that
you will be able to do
um and uh one of the things that i want
to mention is that what you saw in this
example is just the latest part of it
right but even before that many times
we're faced with data that is not
clearly organized
not easy to deal with as an integrated
data set and each one of the data types
has
very specific properties and so the
first part that we will do in this
program is we will actually try to take
a look at some of the raw data sets and
how to process those data sets to
prepare them for analysis and turn them
into structured data
and to do that i want to briefly talk
about several different types of data
that we will cover in this particular
program so since we're called omix logic
first i will talk about the omix part of
it
so onyx data
could be generated using a variety of
technologies that are all commonly known
as high throughput automated
technologies so high throughput means
that they a single experiment produces
thousands and thousands of measurements
so a lot of measurements these
technologies are automated and so we
need to understand
what does the technology do to produce
the data that we actually study and for
that
we
will take a look at processing steps and
explain how the processing steps are
aligned with the technology itself so
here we have a few examples phenomics so
phenotypic for example imaging of cells
or tissues or organs we have genomics
typically these are variants with some
score so either the number of mutations
that we observe per position or somatic
score for example right so we need to
think about how do we actually turn that
into continuous data if we want to use
some of these models epigenomics we have
chipseek or whole genome by sulfide
sequencing where we analyze dna
methylation and modifications of
chromatin
and transcriptomic data so where we also
measure the gene levels of gene and
transcript expression but also we can
speak about alternative splicing
so now let's take a look at how do these
specific types of data
undergo
processing steps to turn them into
structured data that we can use for
these machine learning and statistical
methods so what is genomic data so
genomic and transcriptomic data a lot of
this is based on shotgun sequencing
shotgun sequencing means that we
generate short reads and then one of the
challenges is aligning those reads to
the right place on the genome so this is
a visualization of a bam file where we
can see how those reads are aligned to
different places and how can we detect
variants and so we'll spend a little bit
of time in this program to talk about
how can we analyze this kind of data in
different ways to turn it into structure
data
once this data is structured we will
then talk about what can you do with
such a table of
genomic variants
of
abundances of different regions for
histone and dna methylation
and of gene expression levels
and one of the important things here is
to understand how
different libraries in r and python can
help us prepare this data into common
structures like matrices and data frames
and the immediate application of that is
to try to understand what does this data
tell us in summary right so we can look
at individual features
how do we actually start evaluating some
of the overall properties of these data
sets and so we'll spend a little bit of
time on what's called exploratory
analysis and exploratory analysis helps
us test these assumptions what is the
distribution or what is the relationship
between individual features
after that we will turn to visualization
so one important part of exploratory
analysis is knowing how to visualize the
right kinds of data with the appropriate
methods so we'll talk about categorical
continuous
discrete data sets we'll talk about
making summaries for categorical data
using cross tabs or what's called pivot
tables we will talk about box plots and
how that helps us understand in summary
the statistical properties but also what
are some of the missing pieces of
information that we can misinterpret
just looking at box plots we'll also
talk about scatter plots and how to
produce a right representation of
continuous data we'll talk about how
this kind of a process of going from
unstructured data to structured data
helps us understand in general what's
going on but we'll also talk about the
importance of filtering ordering and
organizing our data so that we can start
finding patterns that are meaningful and
what does meaning really means
and then we will talk about in the
overall process how do these individual
steps fit into a data science approach
to these kinds of big data sets so we'll
talk about
how is data collected how then it is
prepared for exploratory analysis what
can we do to mine this data and find
important patterns and how do we deploy
strategies for data analysis statistical
modeling or machine learning to produce
reliable and reproducible
findings that we call inference right
how do we understand what the data is
telling us and how can we use that to
make next steps conclusions to ask new
questions right what comes after we
perform all of these steps and
importantly when we talk about
the kind of generalizable findings that
we have in our data how do we actually
think about the quality of our findings
so how confident can we be in our
findings how deployable and
generalizable are the models that we
train
and so there are a lot of useful
libraries and interesting examples that
we will go through in r as well as in
python and kind of really talk about
some of the
linkages between the statistical
properties of data and biological
interpretation and again because we are
going to be using curated data sets
we're also going to be paying a lot of
attention to validating what we find
both in terms of its statistical
properties but also looking at
literature and understanding why what we
are finding is a reliable pattern or a
pattern that we can test and validate
biologically so specifically i think
this is
targeting some of the people that come
from more of a biology or a clinical
background that maybe don't have as much
trust in pure statistics and machine
learning but really would like to
understand why
and so ultimately the goal for this
program is to understand how all of
these pieces are linked together and
then to be able to find the right pieces
of code that you might need or the right
tools that you might need and learn how
to use them on your own system in your
own environment
and know how to explain the process to
somebody else of how did you actually go
from where you started and where you
ended up and so briefly
to link it back to what we have been uh
doing up until now
let us uh go to the learn portal and
i'll kind of show you where you can
start with uh the program details are
going to be shared with uh by sonalika
in just a few minutes but where can you
start right so let let's say you're not
ready for the program maybe some of the
topics that we discussed today are not
really clear what can you do already
today to kind of evaluate some of these
things for yourself so if you're not
familiar with a lot of the concepts and
topics that i just shared we recommend
for you to start with a course called
bytes and molecules
this is a free course
this free course is available you know
as soon as you sign up and it's a good
way to understand some of the topics
that we briefly covered and
introduce yourself to the variety of
omics data types that we will be dealing
with throughout the program
that includes
dna variation the association between
sequence and structure understanding
next generation sequencing genomics
transcriptomics and metagenomics as well
as thinking about some of the
applications like what we saw presented
by dr
raghav how is this applied to precision
medicine how are these topics useful for
space omics and astronaut health um and
and a brief introduction to
bioinformatics analysis languages so
this is a free course
if you want to try before you commit or
you want to just explore some of these
topics i highly recommend going through
this free introduction
the other
course that i would recommend is called
introduction to bioinformatics right so
many of you might be coming from many
different backgrounds from medicine to
agriculture to biotechnology and so here
we talk a little bit about the
applications of bioinformatics in a
variety of topics that i just described
so how can this be
useful
in a variety of topics there
so the final uh thing that i want to
point to is that the full syllabus of
this program is actually available on
the programs tab right so if you go to
the programs tab you will find here
a variety of different programs
and this particular program is called
uh data science for biomedical data
analysis right uh
yeah
so uh this program is going to start on
december 14th
and we'll cover the things that we
discussed today from statistical
analysis to data visualization and
machine learning and you can find the
detailed syllabus of what topics will be
covered right here in the program and to
talk about this program syllabus and how
you can register i will pass this on
back to songarika